emily you made a film a few years back
with some of your friends
yep what did you learn from the
experience
oh uh there are so many lessons
uh that i took away from the experience
of making like the water
there were a couple of things that were
really clear to me so we made the film
at this sort of watershed moment
in the industry which was when we
started
um uh sort of telling people about the
movie
um and when we finished shooting which
by the way
was from february 2011
to august 2011
so i learned don't try to make a feature
just from
idea to finish in eight months that's
one of the things i learned
but from that period of of 2011
the way that you could write a business
plan fundamentally changed
so um it wasn't just that we learned
that oh i don't know if you're making
an independent drama starring all women
with no sex
and no relationships nobody will fund
that movie
that's one of the things that i learned
another thing that i learned
was that the business was
going to change really rapidly
for a while um so when we started
you could write things about in your
business plan about potential theatrical
releases and the distributors who might
pick you up at which kinds of festivals
and by the end of the time we had
finished shooting new things had popped
up like
ultra vod releases and day and date had
become
a much bigger part of the discussion
no theatrical release at all direct to
consumer was becoming more and more
popular
be partially out of necessity um and
then in the time
subsequent to that while we were
finishing the film and thinking about
going on the festival circuit is when i
would learn
um number one just how difficult it
is if you're waiting to be picked out of
the crowd
by the big festival or by the big
distributor to be part of the 0.004
percent for whom that happens
right that's one thing and i'm totally
willing to assume that i might be in the
99.96 percent or
996 percent um and so
we needed to build better business
models in order to get our films made if
we wanted to continue making them
as something other than a hobby so that
that was really like
the whole process just served to teach
me that the business is in this huge
transition
in this i mean at that moment and
continues to be in transition and will
continue to be in transition for some
time
um and so uncertainty was going to be
you know tumultuous uncertainty was
going to be
kind of the steady state of the business
for the next foreseeable future
you